hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
so ridiculously excited i've been
following this lady on social media for
too long what's happening
hello how did we meet well um i took a
lease option boot camp last may it was
four weeks it was amazing
i did it while i was in canada i had
plans to move over
and um i just wanted to really learn
about property and
who better to learn from but samuel eats
what can i say
so you literally moved from canada
to the peak district
i was way off to the lake district the
lake district
which is nowhere near the peak district
um technically not in the lake district
all right whatever we're here
i'll show you where we are forget
telling you look at this in fact this
house
you bought recently right yes so this
house
how much you pay for it i paid 335 335
grand
yes is that that looks okay reasonable
amount it's a big house though
it's a big house it's a five-bedroom
house
okay we turned it into a six bedroom
nice um we converted hmo
no it's serviced accommodation oh now
listen serviced accommodation
um you weren't very nervous about buying
this house
i did a lot of research you spoke to a
lot of our mentors all the mentors
me included we spent so much time on the
on the phone so talk to me
what what is what is service
accommodation service accommodation is
when you take
a house or building and instead of
renting it out to one person
or a group of people like an hmo you
rent it out for short-term stays
sure i love that what a great what a
great explanation she should be a
trainer maybe one day
um so look you have things like this
service accommodation hot
tub you know and people are paying you
thought when we spoke on the phone
you told me that you thought people
would pay about 250 to 300 pounds a
night
yes that's not the case you were wrong i
was wrong
but very happy to be wrong because how
much are people paying to stay in this
place
they're paying about 500 to 700 pounds a
night
a night tonight 500 to 700 a night
i'm staying here right now with my
family yeah
very first guest in the family i'll show
you around come on patricia
um now this guy by the way he did
nothing this guy
the laziest guy you'll ever he's done
nothing at all no i'm just kidding this
is my like so you guys are married right
yes yes mike what have you been doing
the last two three months and
living and working in this house pretty
much talking about the kitchen
well what can i say i'm just
it's
[Laughter]
this big we actually didn't have to do
very much to it this kitchen isn't
really why we purchased this house
because it was already done no so we
spent all of our time about three months
in renovating the rest of the house and
getting it
all up to a very high standard for our
guests
that's good all right um at least
where's mike where's my i wanna choose
the uh
mike come and show us the lounge what
you did with the lounge he's just put a
fire on
this is this house by the way it's so
big there's so many rooms it's not even
finished yet either is it
it's not good um i'll give you an idea
the standard of the rooms
so you know they're done really nice
this is this is the downstairs room
um our room's upstairs this room is
specifically designed
yeah this room is specifically designed
for people in your group who might have
mobility concerns so we
widened the door frame and then we put
um we took away the carpeting so if
anybody was in a wheelchair
they could be on the ground floor and
enjoy their holiday with the rest of
their family
very nice see thinking about everybody
you can see from the
you know you've got really nice views
we've popped that sucker you're part
literally right outside the front
so parking is easy everything is easy
the lounge i've always thought about
doing this
but never thought it would work but now
what we're probably going to do with our
house
this is the cinema room the kids are in
the cinema room
i think hey ruby joy
no no she's fixated on the tv that is a
projector screen
so just absolutely awesome over here
we have a video game room no a video
game room
i'm excited to be here so
you can hang out here anybody can hang
out and play video games we all like
video games even the adults right
yeah and then you've got your your setup
here
you're just off of the living room so
you're still connected to everybody but
you have your own little credit space to
just
zone out like a bit of a man cave right
so incredible so in terms of the figures
then patricia
so you bought this place for three three
five five
and uh it's a really great place mandy
how's it been so far this day
oh it's been amazing it's been so lovely
how's it nice holiday
yeah i love it we're here for just a
couple nights um
the hot tub as well we're going in that
hot tub okay we're going in the hot tub
the sun's out
3.5 um are you hoping
to refinance it yes so how much what do
you think the valuation will be
once it's like all well it is all
finished
right well based on the performance i'm
going to get a commercial valuation
and hopefully i'm going to be able to
have a value that's about the 500 range
and i'll be able to take out all of my
initial investment and recycle it into
the next project
that's so cool so you're getting a
commercial valuation
let's go upstairs which basically means
a commercial evaluation means it's
getting valued based on the rent
not on the bricks and mortar and because
it's it's running it's almost like a
hotel
a hotel without staff um my room is
probably a real mess
this is our room um but there's how many
rooms in town
six in total one on the ground floor
four on this level
with two bathrooms and one in the loft
right so you can stay here you can a
couple of families
you know family holiday so you're going
to hopefully pull your money out
yes well how much profit after cleaners
channel managers all the systemization
void periods how much
clean profit are you projected to make
per month on this property minimum of
five grand a month yeah and that's what
you told me you were hoping for but
you also told me that you think the
bookings that are coming in it could be
considerably more than that
that's right actually i'm almost fully
booked out for july and august and that
happened before the property was even
finished
so it's um it's going to be probably a
pretty good property i think
yeah absolutely so five grand that has
been quite conservative isn't it
yes that is being very very very
conservative
too conservative she doesn't like to
jinx stuff but
but look a shower walk-in shower um
under floor heating and as well you had
lots of choices to make you were
thinking
should we put underfloor should we
bother when it's a service accommodation
property
you want to go the extra mile right
definitely you know so talk to me about
that
well i mean you have to make decisions
is it worth the return on investment
and at the end of the day if you're um
trying to aim for a certain type of
client
then you really want to make sure that
you um
sorry make sure that you accommodate
them
so you have to really think about what
this client is normally used to
what luxuries are they used to what
amenities are important to them
and um if they are staying here then
they want their expectations are very
high
so you want to be able to deliver that
and create memories and hopefully
have some loyal customers who keep
wanting to come back and enjoy your
property
yeah that's true you want to go the
extra mile you know this is not a buy to
let
there's not magnolia on the walls cheap
carpets no
you've got you want to go high-end and i
think that you know mike's gonna your
husband
has done a fabulous job as well um where
is mike
at hey hey hey so you you you grew up
here right i did yeah um
so talk to me about the whole canon
thing because i can hear you actually
definitely not from around here so
so you guys when did you meet well we
met in canada
um mike lived in niagara falls and i
lived in a town called oakville which
was just outside of toronto
yeah and um yeah we met we fell in love
and within two months i was on a plane
to england to meet his family and as
soon as i came to
cumbria i fell in love and i thought
well i have to be here
so uh so we made things happen and
within a few years um here we are
and then when we met as well online
because we did like coaching and stuff
like that
you were living in canada working in a
job
desperate to be financially free and
moved here and and now
like that's all happened absolutely and
you know that's the thing i was
desperate to be financially free i was
really tired of working these endless
hours for somebody
else and just the anxiety and the stress
it was too much for me and i knew i
couldn't keep it up
and i thought how can i do this and then
you know you just do
a really easy google search and samuel
elise comes up with all of his
training his mentorship his programs his
support
and we could not have done this without
this man so we're
absolutely grateful i really appreciate
it how's the you're on the academy how's
the academy been
love the academy hello academy friends
love you guys
ricky everyone else yeah it's been such
a great support team and community
great and it's been so good you guys are
such an awesome couple so thank you so
much for letting us stay here you need
to come down to stone arthur you're
right there luke my family
love it amanda loves it would you say to
someone that was thinking about coming
and staying here amanda don't think
about it just books
just bookmark also it all starts at the
crash course so come and get
booked on the crash course you'll
probably are you guys coming to the
crest course yeah yes
june he's samuel's all over again
check it out you must go it's amazing
you'll meet some really great people too
and um just get educated that's the very
first step absolutely
awesome there we go guys peace out
subscribe
come to the crash course watch more
videos check these guys out
and we will see you next time peace